I just beat up a lot of children in
chess and in this video you're going to
see all my games from the chess kid
versus streamers
battle tournament it was a friendly
match I was on a team with Gotham chess
and the crownling and Grandmaster
archers night songs and we were up
against a very talented team of Juniors
there was Tani there was Brewington
there was Megan paragua and there was
Alice Lee who was fresh off drawing
Hikaru in the Pro chess League just a
few days ago it was a double round robin
format so I played every kid with white
and with black and I had a really
unexpected result which you'll see what
I mean if you watch the whole video now
a couple things to note
I did have a really bad headache
throughout the Stream So if you see me
like grasping my head uh I was in some
pain there was also some video lag
issues I think my PC had a hard time
supporting the zoom call that just had
so much talent on it so please forgive
it and I hope the chess makes up for it
and yeah enjoy oh it's starting
okay
I'm giving small time odds
now I realize it started
here we go
okay
layout should be okay I hope
all right first game against Tawny
uh this is already a pleasant line for
white
Knight G5
going after this Pawn
my dn94 as well
I've had this position before
okay not the worst thing ever to give
some time odds
up on time now
in Bishop C4 now
98 94.
maybe just castling
casting Queen side looks nice
here
I actually had an over the board game
you know a very similar line recently
played the rapid uh rapid quad at St
Louis chess club a few days ago
but in that game there was a bishop on
E7 Pawn back on A7
Castle
Bishop E6 takes takes
wait a minute
idea here
V6
I also have 94.
Castle Bishop B6 takes on tape
and probably queen queen E4 there
looks nice
also bisbee6 I could play Queen E4
immediately
as a dream position everything's
developed
Japan's a bit weak now you four is a
threat
the calculation is Bishop E6
I think just queen of Bishop five
okay so what happens if I take
I still have 94.
um
I'm just trying to stay focused here
the Whitney six I just take and then
when D6
and then go to some end game up upon
okay
take on G6 with a rook
and then Rook
uh
calculates
looks really good
the point is after
um Bishop takes Rook I have Rook D1
many cases I win the queen
I think black has to take everything
also just
losing
so if King C7 I take take in the queen
E7 the queen would be pinned
okay
I take
I'm down the full Rook here so I do have
to be careful
on H7 now
taking on D6 and then
just take on each side
eventually I'll take on D6 and probably
end up winning the G7 Pawn
and it'll be queen Queen in like a few
pawns for two Rooks
okay time's taking down
well time is a little bit laggy but
okay
I have plenty of time
now I can take
[Music]
um
I'll click on C5
I'm gonna win one of the Rooks
my symmetry here
okay
I'm not gonna get swept
I was scared like that I might go into
this and lose all my games but
I mean really he just walked into like
um
kind of a offbeat opening trick this
Knight C3 line and
it wasn't easy for black to recover
so okay
um
Focus here let's play lots of with the
roslimo
the E6
we did Play Over the board at Chicago
open I feel like he also played the sign
it's a tricky variation I think Bishop
E3 is like the trendy move
I did have this line in Reykjavik
when like Bishop E3 takes takes Knight
D5
yeah this is also a line
goes um and this is Theory but King d8
and then there's about 494
it's been a while since I looked at this
but um in Knight E4 is like the last
move of preparation that I remember
um
and it's supposed to equalize
choose attacked whites if White Queen
side castles and F2 becomes very weak
King E7
maybe Knight D4
I can't complain with this maybe a more
like positional queenless middle game
already starting to head towards end
game
up on time too
and maybe he's calculating Knight C7
Rook B8
don't think it leads to much though
also I I could take on F2 first
Bishop E3 okay
we'll probably take an A6
in 69 T4 Bishop D7
and time management is good
foreign
what to do here
I'm kind of Rook C8
I'm gonna play E5 it doesn't quite work
C8 looks natural
[Music]
E4 might be coming
my idea to play this and then this
traveling E4 Knight G4 takes H3 Knight
F6 E5
Knight G5
maybe it's worth playing this move
this is hard to prevent E5
although am I really scared of that
let's see Knight G5 Knight G4
the trio I have 95 so takes takes H3
Knight F6 e597
95 Rook C8
it's okay for me actually
so again the calculation is takes takes
H3 Knight F6 it seems like I waste a
couple 10p
but it's worth getting the bishop to C6
I'll be attacking the pawn E5
and the Knight E7
it goes for rookie one
I really want to play E5
six
you just Rook d8
move the pieces
yeah the Knight Will reroute
I want to keep it very positional
he's like beast when it comes to tactics
[Music]
um
realizing there's a small issue here
although Maybe
that's not a huge concern
I'm threatening this if Knight D2 I can
take
at the undefended bishop
I was worried about uh the Knight coming
to D6
but it's hard to get there
because there's this maneuver but
leave the bishop
as a Target
or
you start with Bishop
Bishop D5 looks logical
tickling the pawn
maybe some B5 B4 ideas
I don't know what to do so it's kind of
just a waiting move
no longer have to worry about Bishop
takes H7
lights tied down to the pond
a logical move
let's go for
it's too committal he Rook C7
Rook C5
trying to just pressure this Pawn so one
idea is B5 Bishop B7 to attack
Bishop doesn't have a great Square
in Bishop A2
is one way to attack the pawn
seems too artificial
I'll play this
is freeing up the square for the bishop
this would be seven
or Bishop C4
maybe bishop C4 first
oh I have to watch out for Knight C6
ideas
Rook B8
really have to watch over counter play
Rook B maybe makes the most sense
B file could be useful
falling below 10 seconds
there's maybe four is maybe a threat
before I have rugby Savannah
E3 is weak Knight G3 is a threat
it3
first
oh
um
I'm winning a piece maybe not
in Rook G5
I looks nice
he resigned
okay
overall I think it was a smooth game I'm
gonna get some more water but that's as
good of a start I could have asked for
this is a chess kid broadcast
shout out to James Canty and
Jesse cry
oh it's five to three okay so we're up
by two
okay so that's a good start for us here
we go
E4 it is
I just played this before like F3 and
queen D2 Bishop C4 is like the main line
though
oh
this is okay this might be some like
weird Gambit type line
um
yeah I'm actually not familiar with this
takes like B8
looks playable
I'm not experienced enough with the
accelerated dragon to
like know the theory
but
I know how to not get a checkmated
immediately
so I think the goal is to play Bishop B7
and like Target the Pawns G2 B2 and E5
are all potential weaknesses
not sure what to expect be castling
V2 is a bit poisonous though because
Bishop B3
so let's start with this
and queen
in Queen C5
what am I doing here
okay Queen C5 I have Rook C8 Queen A7
Bishop G2 I think
that's still tricky
it's nice having initiative
oh it looks like he doesn't have the
best internet connection
oops what did I do
wait how do I get rid of the there we go
I don't want to break
wanna break anything
uh Bishop takes E5
I have two summer Pawns
really want to do things against the
king
and B2 is hanging
say this
I think Queen C7
Queen C7 will have the triple thread of
this this and also Bishop G2 hitting A7
I could take on H2
go into the end game
off the card Bishops
um
I'm thinking Bishop B8
like a really tricky move
I should probably just win back material
one disconnected
I can just play What's Happening
opponent reconnected okay
um
realizing G3 I might have Queen C6
there's no need though I should just
take the bishop
um most of my pawns haven't moved yet
all of White's pawns haven't moved yet
I'm probably choosing between this this
and this
maybe this
oh there's a calculation this this and
then this
but then I have F6 and if takes I just
take the bishop
okay that's kind of fortunate
okay
this is a nice Square for the bishop
because then I can follow the D5
it's just a wooden Shield that that's
called The Wooden Shield
so what is Shield
Bang Pow bing boom quad that's the
wooden Shield
yeah obstacle Bishops sometimes have a
drawish tendency but
it's a three result game
like a lot can happen here because the
structure is so imbalanced
I have the king side pawns white has the
queen side Pawns
let's start with this
I think I'll just oops not Mouse slip
have to be really careful
I wasn't sure there
King really wants to come in
probably to C4
there's this move
you hear this first
also play Rook H3 while
we'll play this
it's getting a little bit risky though
ready to play H5
oh
wow
like D5
H5
maybe a fight for the G file
I see I have this Rook G4 idea looks
nice
The Rook G3 Rook G4 is critical
all right he's controlling h8
in this move
yeah the bishop stops all the Pawns
the H4 there there
H4 works
they win the bishop
a little tricky though
it's safest to take
okay he disconnected but
uh final position is winning because
take on C3 and take on F4
okay
um
I was fortunate there
I think H4 is a nice kind of
breakthrough move
okay
um new game
yeah last time we okay C5
uh
let's play this
play the most principled approach F5 I
used to play this
uh what's the line
Knight C3
what is the line
Bishop G5
I know there's E4 takes and then G4
there's a game between Yasser sarawan
and Mama Dr of
I went something like this
I went through a phase of playing this
line as black back when I was uh
um back when I was an FM but actually
the opening I used is black to get my IM
title
it's really interesting a lot of players
don't know how to deal with it
I'm pretty sure Mama diara played D6 and
then he also played H3
the G5 might also be a move
or wait how did it go
maybe maybe G6 doesn't move here
I'm forgetting
yeah I mean this is one of like the most
critical lines I think against this
opening
I call this uh muhana formation
I just called this the benoni Dutch c5f5
I think I think
played two games I'm a little confused
back to the Anna crownling yeah oh
I think like he challenged me instead of
I like mute the
um the like automatic period not
accepted for that and that occurring but
then like after it started the automatic
period happened like after the time
another mute
what's up Anna
I'm using on the zoom call which is good
thankfully it wasn't too distracting I
am still in some opening prep
but okay so G6
um Play Bishop G2
I know G yeah G5
let's play this with G2
ideas to eventually win back the pong
okay
and take it right away I think H3 I
remember Yasser like giving a lecture
about his game and really being proud of
H3
like very slow patient play very
methodical
at the way in which Yasser talks
and eventually the pong will
be one back
yeah looks like brewmaster is having
some
connection issues
I keep getting these messages
this is still a fight like box managed
to develop and get an okay position
probably take an E4
making way for the C Pawn potentially
I'll probably end up casting kingside
I don't know if I want to play C4
c4b5
if I take
I like the prospect of taking more
there's Pawn takes
also F5 ticks takes
let's go for this
yeah five is coming
the other plan was just to take
B5
I want to attack the pawn
um not sure how great this position is
a four
there's about four Queen D2
I've take take
me C3
I'm just scared about F5 attacking the
V2 Pawn
it is a little bit slow but
trying to be solid
I just want to get a setup with Queen D2
or okay D1 probably Rook E1
maybe eventually 94
and D6 could be a weakness
I'm gonna try and pressure the clock too
windy seven
I play 94
I just go for rookie one
now if ever F5 I have G5
maybe some simple idea like rookie 2
rookie one
get Rookie 7 eventually
yeah I want to play C4 F5 or B1 Bishop
A6
F5 click on C4
it actually looks okay
trying to clamp down
I thought I could even take on a five
first
Exchange
okay 94 Rook B6
huh
there's a line Knight C5 and then D6
oh it's almost working
um
I'll play Queen G3
there's a trick coming up rook B8 I take
on C5
there's that move wow
um
Rook C3
there we go
that was my trick
not over though
um
Rook beath I have to take
okay
okay saying clean
thank you Mr Alex Goot
appreciate the rain
yeah if you're just joining
um I've played four games so far
there's four more to go
I think I've managed to get by I don't
know who I was most scared of going into
today
maybe Alice Lee
is uh is the one to fear
but I've I was scared like playing
against Tawny and
and Brewington I mean I think I managed
uh almost every game I managed to like
get
a comfortable position from the opening
and that's made a big pretty big
difference
wait who is this
I think this is
I think this is Megan
it actually makes a difference wait let
me check who this is
yeah this is Megan okay
because I did some prep for for Alice
uh back to emo only mode
all right so we have a London
yeah that was not much of a break
okay
so we have the same position
okay slightly different line I had
against Tani
uh let's take
yeah this is a solid line against the
London
Mission D3
I know there's cases where white can
play like C4
here it makes sense to play C3
A4
my idea Knight C4 eventually
and it's a very typical London setup
black has a typical Hedgehog setup
like this
might see Knight D5
I am targeting B6
uh B5
move back
before I have C4
doing low on time
I've played this structure many times
before
actually I first started playing the
structure from the black side I found it
to be annoying
what to do here we can see two
centralize
not really scared of F5
some idea to play Queen A3 and Target
the pawn but
Juan is pretty well defended
every game I've been able to apply
pressure on the clock
usually it's other way around where I'm
getting into time trouble
that's another reason why openings are
so important for like Blitz and rapid
look at the early time that time
advantage and saves time for later
I'm thinking Queen C2
simple move
apply a bit of pressure
made some idea to play Knights eg5 or
Knight fg5
oh we do see i5
I mean Knight G5 looks appealing
because I'm threatening to take take in
D5 or take take and then play Bishop
takes F5
the pawn is a bit tender here
and there is Bishop takes ninth but then
other Knight comes in
I guess there's takes takes and rookie
Eights
trying to calculate that
there's a line where I take on E6
and then play Queen
E3 so let's calculate so takes takes
rookie 96 Rook E6 Queen B3
hitting the bishop
and also threatening this and ideas of
this
yeah it looks looks like there's just
too much fun for white
um
let's still go for the thing
not super simple but
I'll still go for it
F5 is no longer capturable
E5 is possible
there is this move
it could get very crazy
94 could be kind of annoying
there's that move too so I have to take
all right how to do this
I want to play Bishop C4
D5
Bishop A2
[Music]
actually D5 there's Knight E5
intactics
I might as well throw in 95.
the material is equal
the center is opening
looks really close to being really good
I have Queen D2
there's about six
I'm with H7 okay
oh wait no there's Queen G7
we'll start with Queen D2
just a lot of pressure on luck
trying to keep applying it I forgot
about this move
I mean I might be able to take a 96.
click here
threatening made in one
and queen G7 runs into Bishop D6
but this looks really really good
yeah this is also Force mates
okay
so staying still staying clean
um I don't
I don't know if I checked her white
openings
I'm trying to remember
I guess I'll find out shortly
game will start momentarily
and he called me dirty
I don't think I've done like too many
dirty tricks today
it's been a lot of like nice
positional buildups or nice end game
conversions nice opening prep
but maybe at some point I'll have to
resort to dirtiness I play a stature uh
let's um let's stay away from the staff
room
gotta keep it PG
let's play this
okay we have a Russell Nemo
I should have I should have done my
preparation here
and we'll see how much she has prepared
for me
E6 and B5 coming
D5 is a move
the idea would be to take with Queen
if E5 I might even consider
on D4
especially having lights red Bishop
okay this has to be some opening success
um
if I start playing D4
only go for like B5 Bishop B7
and then later in the middle game Target
D3
E3
Castle
assume B3 intends to develop the bishop
and hit my queen
play Queen of five
keeping an eye on D3
I'm actually threatening Bishop F6 to
trap The Rook
hmm
I like the position Bishop pair better
structure
Rook to you is probably coming next I
assume Bishop B2 will be played
the bishop B2 Rook T8 and then rookie
three
and maybe even Knight before
straight for the pawn
yeah white might hold on to it
but there's also like this this and then
B5
Bishop develops
looks very pleasant
okay
it's hard to remove the queen from F5
too
the knights restricted by the bishop
covering E5
yeah assuming rookie three I think I I
go for B5
I didn't want to calculate like this is
I I want to develop my final piece
like so far my lights for admission has
been my worst piece
but very soon it can be one of my best
pieces
I'm calculating 95. I think it's all
okay though
identify we trade Queen G6 I'll be
threatening mates
we need to does allow for Knight D2 and
the pawns defended
maybe something like Queen G6 here
and just beginning to organize some
something
I'm realizing there is this move
although now do you want to have Knight
T4
threading the queen and mates
Knight E4 is a good move
I think completely what I want
I have night before
[Music]
that's not so simple
I'm gonna play F5
it was very anti-positional though
take
the H5 H4
seems a little bit wild but I just want
to prevent Rook G3
in a lot of cases
might even open up ideas upon each three
but this is more of a prophylactic idea
than a attacking idea
I think I should play Pawn B4
not allow the C file to open
it does prevent me from playing Knight
B4 but what to do
maybe there's ideas of pushing the a
pawn
okay
I have to take
H4
this is a prophylaxis
I think the simple plan is to double up
I mean F5 Bishop G5 is almost working
let's just double up
I am smelling tactics Bishop G5
F4 I can take because I'm threatening
mate
do I leave the Rook hanging
[Music]
um
maybe it makes sense
and there
take
I really just want to convert smoothly
there's no need
let's play this
the queen C5 Bishop F3
Bishop g5s with rats
maybe just this for good measure
you can take
it's still not over
let's move
I like the structure now
D3 is forever backwards
like this
wait a minute I can take on e4
oh no my queen
it's only very temporary
um how do I break through
this move
okay there we go
okay
that was another solid game
um I wasn't happy to see the real slimo
but
I got a pretty comfortable position
I think I think the main line is Bishop
F1 like white should keep the lights for
a bishop and then
in many cases go for c3d4
oh Levy's Levy's beating Alice
look at this let's go Levy
oh it's such a happy face
I'll be so strong
I don't think I've ever played Alice Lee
we definitely haven't played over the
board
I mean she's been to St Louis a lot but
usually for like U.S Women's
Championship or these high-level Norm
events
I couldn't find too many games where she
plays against on London
so that will kind of be um
a wild card
I mean let's stick with London though
it's it's been working out today
okay final round starting
emo only mode there you go
okay
okay here we go
my earbuds are out
yeah this is one of the lines I was
expecting
I'm curious if she did any prep for me I
mean I'll find out soon
expecting each three yeah
there's a good chance you check this
it's good to see her thinking here
because if if she had two more moves of
preparation it could be annoying
okay but this line
um
I'm supposed to play Knight H5
not quite remembering though
has some logic to it
yeah we do get the Carlsbad structure
this could get positional
for this
light usually likes to come to C4 but
it's very far away
E4 wow
I have Knight F4
looks like in most cases I do remove the
bishop
I mean black is maybe slightly worse
here
I'm gonna do this
I could take and play C5 Maybe
that's a way to go
I think I'm just in time
it looks risky
pawns are weak I might be gambiting like
I guess there's takes in Rook scene one
after which I probably lose upon like
Queen B6
takes Bishop B7
but maybe I went back upon eventually
I thought that wasn't possible Bishop A6
I mean this was the first thing I
calculated so
I I think she just missed it
and it's it's pretty bad for white
because once I ate the night the Rooks
got fort
okay that was a huge gift
I thought it was on the verge of getting
outplayed there
so I think she usually plays D5
she's also a queen's gamma decline
player I'll play Knight C3
I played this against takaru the last
title Tuesday he played the E6 in that
game
but it's funny because he was also like
kind of out of the preparation
yeah this line is not the most common
usually the knights on F6 not C6
with 9c6 there's some like interesting
ideas
for example Queen A5 is losing
I wonder if she's prepared here
uh what's a line takes
I'm pretty sure I
you sure I'm supposed to play Bishop C7
running Rook d8
I studied this months ago
but there's a really cool idea after
Bishop B7 there's H4 Rook H3
like the the one thing I remember
and also if the bishop develops this way
there's uh bismay 6.
the Trap The Rook
I do remember the engine says Bishop G4
is possible but after F3
it's not easy for black to play
yeah I was actually hoping to get this
line against sakaru
because it's not the most well-known
and I mean especially if we get this
like engine idea
objectively it is equal though I think
it's a bit easier for white to play
E5
that move gives me more of a headache
and I gotta play Rook D AIDS
and then you tape
I can take the rook and take the pawn
I guess it's not a huge I don't know if
it's any Edge for lights
this extra Pawn I'm up is just a double
t-pong
but I shouldn't be worse here
it was a funny position like we're both
undeveloped on my king side like
approaching that in-game
King D7
let's start with an F3
E5 Bishop B5 check
um
how valuable is a bishop hair
it's pretty valuable
ah but
yeah let's go for this range provoke C5
there's a situation where I allow her to
take and
oh no my Pawn structure
oh
she doesn't go for it
a bishop D3
we're threatening this
I've developed uh all my minor pieces
the oxmeier pieces are not so developed
that's a question by Castle
[Music]
by Pawn C4 have King E2
E2
delayed Bond Cloud I want to play C4
it gets very positional though
it is first
I'm not concerned about G2 so I can win
G7
I really want to play 94.
actually D6 and C5
oh there is an id5
okay
to keep in mind I'm up a pond so if we
trade C Pawns
that'll be nice
four is coming
um
R4 is very committal
probably play this and then look to play
C4
rookie eight and D3 Maybe
where is the night going
you're gonna just play Rook B1
idea Rook B7 not scared of the discovery
checks
the king might just find shelter on one
of these squares
or maybe it becomes active
D3 Knight B6
I'm seeing a setup
with um assuming Knight P6 I have C4
Bishop D5
and that's just uh very very solid
like Rook d8 Bishop D5
E4 maybe the event of Rook compute
also some idea of rookie one to take and
then take
a rookie is coming
maybe King F3
if I take the X takes rookie two
picking up three
each four or G5 maybe H4 H6 takes takes
Rook H1
Bishop A5
in these lines but they're not so simple
okay so the idea is if Knight takes I
take the bishop and I win one of the
Pawns
Bishop moves I probably played Bishop A5
or take on F4
um
take
it's not so simple
go for this um
fabric
E1 I can also tick tick
to go for this
I'm up two Pawns
um
each Pawn is going to be running
there we go
oh that's close
um oh no my queen
oh no my queen
okay
good game that was good fight
like
even even towards the very end of the
rook and bond versus broken three Pawns
I wasn't entirely confident
so the team score is 11 19.
this is uh um
the official broadcast
and I'll probably send a read to the
official broadcast
but also probably put like all these
games on YouTube
so if you're watching the future on
YouTube
congratulations winning eight out of
eight
thank you Phil stew and we are bad guys
we are back of course with the man
himself right uh Eric Rosen I am Eric
Rosen after this performance that's what
he goes by you got to say it all in one
sentence I am Eric Rosen right so very
nice of course here we got Jesse cry to
his old Grandmaster and international
Master Eric Rosen uh that was nice Jesse
let's start with you man what you got to
say to Eric about this performance well
first of all I just want to say for all
the old people at AR double ARP we're
very happy we needed this boost man
because these kids are telling us how to
do computer stuff how to use my phone my
daughter's telling me how to use my
phone she's six years old though wow so
we get this big kind of beat down it
just gives us faith in humanity you know
maybe just for one more day just for one
more day just for one more that feels
good there I felt that that's nice Eric
congratulations bro you doing eight out
of eight so were you like mad at the
kids or something like explain to us how
this eight out of eight with this field
of these strong kids happen oh no I I
wasn't angry at all I was just trying to
to play quickly and
um I I think a lot of the games I was
just in my comfort zone early on like I
got all the openings I was going for
um I I did a little bit of prep for
every opponent and that kind of went a
far away because with every game I had a
Time Advantage from early on
um maybe with exception of my first game
against Alice she got a slightly better
opening but uh yeah it's nice to kind of
get the opening preparation that I
looked at like right beforehand so uh
fairly no complaints
now James you called it because he I'll
tell you Eric we were watching you play
and he said he talks so smoothly as if
he's so nice but really he's a stone
cold killer and and that's that's what I
just witnessed from you right there it's
all nice and sweet all nice and sweet
but we saw what you did we we still got
to clean up the blood after all this
it's over man
yeah like I kind of want to feel bad for
like winning all my games but at the
same time yeah I think there's a lot of
lessons to take away like with every
opponent's um like they really need to
uh to do more preparation when it comes
to the openings because a lot of the
lines I played I played a lot before
online and it can really help to like
look up your opponent's repertoire
before the game and and have an idea of
what to expect
yeah
it's very nice there Eric as uh you just
show you came here showed out eight it
was actually you guys won I think by
eight points so yeah you want to buy
eight clean so it's kind of like just
all eight came from Eric no but at the
same time it was a team effort very good
job so that was awesome and uh great
prep man great preparation as is yeah I
guess that everyone can learn from that
guys listening and watching preparation
right good prep I will say the uh the
streamers got crushed the first event so
I think enough rage built up that we
really wanted Revenge this time exactly
right especially with free us too as
well it's just going crazy there get
Alice Lee here now uh I actually only
finished with at 50 with four points so
nice job there Eric anything you want to
say to the chat and people watching and
the kids and people that look up to you
and also
um you know the kids that uh you just
beat back so you just got everyone here
I think it's it's really important like
it's so easy these days to get attached
to just pure the winning or or chasing
like a certain reading or chasing a
certain title but especially when you're
younger it's so important to just have a
growth mindset and learn as much as you
can from every single game especially
the traws and the losses and uh that's
that's what makes you a better player
over time and take advantage of the
facts especially for the younger people
watching that your your brain is is more
capable of absorbing more information
compared to someone like me or Levy or
Jesse where it's sometimes slower for us
to actually absorb information these
days so uh yeah take advantage of being
young very nice very nice you got
anything for him Jesse before we get out
of here I want to ask one last thing I
know you're hanging out there in St
Louis you got all that chest Talent
around you and I just want to know man
what's the dream of the you know I am
Rosen becoming GM Rosen that's I want to
know the status of that Journey
oh you asked me the same question last
time every time but it's gonna keep
coming too I don't think much has
changed
um I played a couple local events I
played like the rapid quads at the club
the other day I played the blitz
tournament yesterday
um this morning we went to a farm and
saw some goats with one of your fellow
dojos
um but I'm trying to enjoy life here and
uh I'm not like seriously chasing the GM
title but I will be playing uh the super
Swiss in Vegas coming up so that's like
my next kind of big tournament but I'm
just trying to enjoy chess and
um try and keep improving but not
necessarily get Norms or get a title or
anything or anything like that I'm gonna
ask you next time too I'll be ready for
it it'll be ready for it well Eric Rosen
guys of course star of today eight out
of eight for the streamers as the
streamers won over the kids today so
great job Eric thanks so much guys